Welcome to the Anne and Ashley show.
I'm Ashley and I'm Ann.
Coming at you live from Conno's Clinic.
Be sure to hit the subscribe, like,
and follow our social media platforms.
We don't want you to miss any of our episodes.
I just have to have to.
Today we are discussing part two of the EMF series.
We will be discussing ways to protect yourself
from them through products or supplements.
We will also be discussing ways
to make us more individualized
and also how to protect your kids in your home.
So Ann, why are we so individualized?
Well really there's a lot of things
that make us individualized
as far as our susceptibility and our risk
for EMF exposure, our sensitivity to it.
Genetics play a huge role.
We actually know that there are genes
that are linked to a person potentially having a sensitivity.
So if you have variants on those genes,
you're more likely to experience a lot of those symptoms
that we talked about in part one,
the brain fog fatigue, you know,
dry pain, those types of things.
If you have these variants in your genes,
there's genes that are involved in DNA every pair.
So if you have variants in those genes,
you might be more susceptible to the damaging effects
of the radiation genes that are involved
in mitochondrial health.
So, so yes, looking at an individual's genetics,
you know, we can zero in more closely and customize
somebody as far as maybe some supplements
that could help with any EMF exposure.
So we do have some supplements here.
This is body bio PC.
This is phosphotythic colon,
which really works to help maintain the integrity
of the cell membrane.
Again, when I'm talking about EMF exposure,
we're damaging the cells.
And so there's actually been studies shown,
you were just showing me the other day, those images
of studies where they are looking at cells
and then putting an EMF,
they're exposing the cells to EMFs.
And then looking at the damage first hand
of what's happening to those cells
and you can see the membrane of the cell
just kind of disintegrates, the cells are all mistraping.
So body bio PC, the phosphotythic colon,
really helps support the integrity of that cell membrane.
And that was specifically on the smart meters too.
Oh, that was in relation to the smart meters.
Oh, geez, yeah, that was bad.
And these two here are really,
this is mitochondrial and energy support.
And then this is something called
peroxid nitrate scavenger.
So these work to help support DNA in the mitochondria.
So these are all great options.
Also, you know, Ashley mentioned in part one,
just talking about food and nutrition,
making sure you're getting plenty of antioxidant rich foods
in your vegetables, you know, eating a rainbow,
the fruits and vegetables,
so try to get as many colors in your food every day.
It's really gonna help support the integrity of your cells.
So yeah, those are great supplements for that.
And with kids going back to school,
if they aren't able to swallow a supplement
or take nutritional peace, don't like supplements.
So, you know, that's interesting that we have other ways.
Yeah, these other products that we'll discuss here
in a second.
Did you know, Y-Fi has more radiation
than just one single cell tower?
That is kind of freaky because that is in our house.
And a lot of people have multiple Y-Fi routers
because they want instant connection.
Yeah, and now that's surrounded by your kids at school.
Yeah.
Multiple Y-Fi routers at school,
so your kids are going into this classroom
when they all own a cell phone,
and then they all have Y-Fi connected to their laptop set
and now schools provide for them.
And they're just bombarded with all this EMF exposure
all day long, with no protection
if they have that genetic defective reaction.
It's 10 times worse for those kids,
especially if they already have a learning problem in some way
that it's gonna make it 10 times harder for them to start learning
and maintain their memory.
And it's just so hard on the brain because those kids,
their brains are still developing.
And they have a thinner bone structure than adults,
so the radiation can see right through their brain cavity.
Their cell structure is constantly replicating.
So if they're replicating so fast
and now they're getting damaged cells from these EMFs,
then they're now replicating damaged cells
in long-term effect is a health concern.
So these parents are starting to go to their local city
or whoever it might be to stop those cell towers
from being so close to their schools.
They've been putting the high-voltage power lines
200 feet away from playgrounds in schools
and it's a health concern for these parents.
And they're not even notified
that this is happening.
That's just not even a letter.
Yeah, and so it's just the long-term effects,
short-term effects, parents have also noticed
all those symptoms going on that we talked about in part one.
And just now, and also they've noticed
those symptoms go away on the weekend
when they're not in school.
So they correlate themselves with all this EMF exposure.
So we have a ton of extra devices here
that hopefully will help your kid that you can provide them
with some reduced EMF products to send them with school
and at home, too.
Right, so, yeah.
So, you know, if you can maybe think of the one thing
that your kid always has, even us as adults,
it's, you know, your cell phone, you always have your cell phone
on you.
I swear it's the one thing that my kids don't lose.
Isn't the cell phone you lose anything else?
The cell phone, which is good.
Yes, they're obviously expensive.
So, cell phone protection.
So we have a couple different options of cell phone protection.
So, he drawn a sticker for the back of your phone.
I can go on your phone or on a cell case,
your cell phone case that helps to reduce the exposure.
Also, your cell phone not sleeping next to it.
Right.
And so even if it's protective, still do not sleep next to it.
That has been, there have been some studies with that.
As mentioned in Part One, but also we did read up a little bit
more that some parents have had.
There are little kids even who own cell phones
sleep with that under their pillow.
And it's just all night exposure directly to their head.
Yeah, teenagers who never want to miss anything.
Yeah, keep it up right next to them, not good.
And, yeah, so keeping it away from them, turning Wi-Fi off at night.
We also have this, this is Carl called an R2L.
This is a different device that you can put on your phones.
And you put it on a different location depending on what type of phone
you have.
We'll link information, more information on each of these items
that we're talking about, so you can do some more research on them.
Yeah, and then a phone, an actual phone case.
So my ins and outs stuck on there yet.
But you can see you placed your phone right here on the sticker.
And then when you close it, it's how you actually will
talk right through it through the speaker.
Doesn't mess with it at all, with having it in close test.
Yeah, you can be able to talk when there's something.
Exactly.
And then you just slide it up to take a picture.
But you're like, yeah, but you're fully protective now
with instead of just talking where it's emitting right on you
and producing all that heat, you now protect the screen,
even which reduces the EMF coming out of the case against your scan.
So this is pretty cool, I think.
Yes.
And so that's this one here.
And the other things that kids always have too are an iPad or a laptop.
So this is a heat drum harmonizer that's larger.
So for larger devices, an iPad, a laptop,
you can put this on a gaming console, on a refrigerator.
You know, it's listed here.
It's you can put it on your Wi-Fi router, desktop computer,
on a cordless phone, if anybody has those anymore.
TV refrigerators, so all of those things.
Yeah, and here are the cases for your computer laptop.
So it's a really nice protective case.
This part, you open it up, and this part here
can work as, you know, like the area for the mouse.
So tracking device, so it's protective as far as just scratches
from your computer, but then also from the radiation.
So that's a great sleeve.
So this is the iPad standard sleeve that usually comes with iPads.
So you can just see it's a basic, thin piece of equipment.
But then we have this one that actually you place the iPad right in here.
And so it works as a protector as well.
But also now you have the EMF protector.
And when we tested this one, when it stands,
this piece is what actually helps absorb the EMF.
So if it was just laid down flat on it,
it's not going to be as powerful as standing up,
just because of that extra pad.
So that was pretty cool to see.
All right, so what else can we do?
We are from kind of the devices.
Oh, the body shield.
Yes, so this is a little huge, round shield
that you can keep with you in your pocket on your body.
So it's just helping you wherever you go as body protection.
Then we have hijun headphones.
So of course, kids, adults even too,
constantly wear headphones when you're working out,
when you're studying, really anything
will seem to be a podcast or an out of all.
So these headphones specifically
have these little barrels on them, which
help pull out the excess EMF radiation
by the time it gets to your ears.
Anything wired is going to be really beneficial.
So even at home, if you can make things more wired,
you're going to reduce the EMF exposure already.
And then to get rid of this much blue tooth, as you can.
Yeah, and with the blue tooth, we have this blue tooth
adapter.
A adapter.
Can you write a blue tooth?
Well, yeah, blue tooth is kind of hard-wired.
Hard-wired is best.
If you do blue tooth, though, you could use an adapter.
And this adapter will help with any, like I think
he said, iPhones don't have a cord anymore to plug
the anti-phones.
So you could use this adapter to plug your headphones in any
headphone, but these ones would be probably best.
And then this would act as the wireless adapter then.
So you could still have wireless headphones, even
with a wire with an adapter.
Full of them that I've had.
I'd forget what they're called.
Your buds, I'd use.
Yeah, and then blue tooth.
Oh, the speaker.
Yeah, yep, on your ear.
Those are pretty bad.
The blue tooth in your car, too, is not the best.
But hands-free law.
So we have to do anyway.
So a body shield will probably be best.
And yeah, your key point of view is, oh, this one, too,
is for a room.
Oh, yes.
So this is for the room that you have your Wi-Fi router in.
But this one, so this might be something to have in your car.
Oh, yeah.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
That's the big one.
And then we have these plugins.
These ones are good for, how many rooms was that?
One, I think it's your whole house.
Is the level, right?
Well, I don't know.
I thought these were for the whole, just the whole house.
And it might be a certain of a square space.
I think so.
But yeah, so these ones, so you get to when
you make a purchase for these plugs to kind of protect
your whole home.
And you plug one.
And if you're looking at your electrical panel,
you plug one into an outlet that's
associated with the right side of your electrical panel.
And then you plug the other one in an outlet that's associated
with the left side.
Yes.
And then it helps to protect your home.
That was right.
Yep.
Yeah.
OK.
There's also something that you can hard
wire to your home that is, I don't know.
I think it's thousands of dollars.
But it's more of a hard wiring from protective.
You can also use a draganate.
So when you go around your house, as close as you can to your house,
it's like a rock dirt mixer that you just kind of spread
in the soil.
And it just kind of seeps in to help your house be grounded.
So any EMF power, especially if you look
at high voltage power lines, too, it gets drawn to the draganate
not onto your house itself.
That may be something alongside this to get on your home.
Another thing that we use, I purchased this of a daughter.
I just want to have to college.
And so I put this.
This is a pad that can go either on a chair or on a bed.
I put it on her bed because I just was thinking,
oh my gosh, she's in the storm.
Again, all the maintenance like being in school,
just hundreds of people with Wi-Fi and cell phones and computers.
And so how can I help her?
And so it's a grounding mat.
So you literally just lay on this.
There's a plug that goes into just the ground port of an outlet.
And it helps to just draw the harmful positive ions out
of your body and then disperses them into the ground.
So I got this for her and really I'd like to get this
for everyone in my family because I feel like you're in your bed
for maybe six to eight hours per night.
So you can spend that whole time just getting rid
of those negative ions or the positive harmful ions
to become grounded.
And that's great.
That was a really good idea for her.
Yes, I thought it was a nice gift.
She's like, what are you doing?
Oh my gosh.
And then of course, we have our salt lamp here.
And then these are the stones or rocks you're talking about.
It doesn't necessarily have to be this big,
but just an idea for something for you
to hold on while you're on your device.
Draw the energy too plus they look really nice.
And so you could just have it as decor around your house.
So that's all of our devices.
We do have a demo we'd like to show you guys.
So we'll just load up a music app really quick
just to show you people listen to music
all the time.
So you can see it's pretty high of 140 constantly up and down
here under the mirror.
Yeah, so that one's really high.
So then we close this and now look
at how low it stays still playing music.
So that's pretty cool of how well this works
because of course, this is the part against your face
when something's emitting.
Right, when you're talking on a phone.
Yeah, so it's pretty.
It's not supposed to significantly.
Yeah, that was pretty cool.
So that concludes our second part of the EMF series.
We are going to do another part three
where we're going to hit on 5G.
It's kind of an emerging topic
and whether we like it or not,
something that we should be concerned about.
So we'll talk about that in the next episodes.
Hopefully you got some good information.
Please, again, like and subscribe
to our social media platforms.
Share this episode with your friends,
help protect your friends as well.
And we look forward to seeing you in part three
of the EMF series.
Thank you for watching.